hey guys welcome to honest trailer
commentaries the show where we talk
about the other show that you hopefully
just watch to hear about our thoughts
our cut jokes our true feelings about it
and as I said before if you stick around
you will see the things that got cut now
of the episode we're not being good
enough that's your prize for watching
this video I'm Spencer Shay gilbert
that's Joestar that's Dan merle i just
shows a zone where my headphones a
second ago so i took them off that's
fine yeah sorry about it we all watched
blade we made some jokes about it i
think this was your first time through i
had not seen any of the blades yeah I
couldn't I was too young to see the
first one when it came out and so I
never caught up to them and this is my
first exposure to bleed
what's your first fresh take a blade
virgin it's it's good I mean the first
food was like pretty good and then the
second movies like Guillermo del Toro
like really cool visuals and stuff it's
not very good yeah so you know I've
certainly seen worse yes I was because I
have a little bit of like blade
nostalgia like I have blade goggles a
little bit so it's hard to be too mean
to them so I was curious what you I'd
heard so much about blade Trinity about
how just like awful it was and I mean I
guess in comparison to the other two
like it's definitely not a good movie
but wow this is terrible but God really
as a movie made so little out of so much
that's true you have such an amazing
collection of talent like the
best-in-show people randomly in it and
you have you know they've really built
up something cool like I would argue
that one was great two was better and
then three it's like yeah a Dracula was
the obvious yeah like this weird like
German party boy dress yeah ready to die
we didn't get into enough but yeah like
a weird Rome apparently the full the
story was supposed to be about that like
vampire Final Solution where they're
gonna like it was supposed to take place
after they'd succeeded in that and
they're only a few humans left the
studio was like that's too dark have
them fight Dracula party boy party boy
oh it's interesting that there was once
a time where a studio told David Goyer
no that's too dark
[Laughter]
yeah you can see David glares
fingerprints on this and by the way four
blade one and two it totally works it's
a dark r-rated vampire movie I think
that's why it worked why he works well
with Batman and also why he doesn't
worry man yeah and he works great there
I think there are people he works with
that like rein in his worst tendencies
and then bring out the best in them so
blade 1 & 2 or pretty solid I guess you
know del Toro was like no no I want that
to look beautiful not dark and they
complemented each other well and then
for the third one Gore was like and now
I got this and yeah man we touched on
that in the trailer but those behind the
scenes stories are incredible yes yes
some of the better ones I've ever heard
but yeah I'm a blade apologist I love
the first movie I loved the first two
and I think that like why is it is it
only the tax evasion stuff that's
keeping much the Snipes from being in
more movies right like what guess and he
kind of has like a sort of a later era
Nicolas Cage but also kind of like his
like his performances and these movies
are like what's appealing about them is
like I'm not sure if he's I think he
knows what he's doing because a lot of
people might looking at me like like it
seems trying to do that yeah but it's
it's so kind of odd and bizarre and like
it's I don't know it's hard that was the
most appealing thing for me was like I
don't know what Wesley Snipes is doing
in these movies but I like it yeah it's
weird yeah super crazy it's I sometimes
I think he's like making fun of the fact
that he is playing a day walking vampire
it's or he's like way too in way too
into it yes the self-awareness question
is true because these guys kind of lose
that grip on reality like Steven Seagal
I think his times yes yeah and
jean-claude van damme has like a whole
series about blurring that line so these
eighties guys you do enough drugs and do
enough kung-fu and I think that you
forget where movies end and your life
begins yeah let's watch a movie an
honest trailer of one at least Blade
trilogy now we're gonna watch all three
in their entirety right yes
sit back settle in it's done in
conjunction with bike engine yes in a
time when Marvel movies were
direct-to-video flops unreleased cult
films or whatever Howard the Duck was
the best and worst of marble were on
full display the Blade trilogy points
your thirst with three movies of wildly
different quality than at their best
could make bila stars look cool and work
we debated how to describe Stephen Dorff
yeah we always were first draft it was
like I think it was just like terrible
actors look great or something yeah we
had to be like this is terrible actor
and then we did a deep dive into Stephen
Dorff IMDB yeah and found out that
either he's not a good actor or he just
hasn't given been given the chance to
shine because he's in a lot of movies
that none of us had ever heard of yeah
we see a lot of movies I just remember
he was the first person I ever saw
endorsed it wasn't called that at the
time vaping like he was a coffee blue he
the blue cigarette which is speed
Stephen Dorff was like the first
celebrity vapor that I remember for me
yeah yeah ground floor he was in on he
knew he knew what was going on
Oh Dorf vapes he needs a career
Renaissance like Skeet Ulrich got on
Riverdale like he needs he needs a good
CW show to land on yeah okay I'll take
your word for it yeah he's good on that
well yeah deep deep dive on Dorf that's
why you're watching the dark dive deep
down bars look cool and at their worst
make a list actors look ridiculous
that's just rude
all thanks to directors that range from
the unknown to those I never did
anything on the PG out of comic book
movies dark or trip-hop
whatever kids listening to these days
explain the Simpsons references the
Poochie episode which I hope is still
relevant or at least people you always a
reference which was a studio mandating
that itchy and scratchy add a new
character Poochie
who like needed to have he was just a
living studio note he needed to have
attitude he needed to rap you need to be
a surfer he needs to like be
all these nebulous things and I do think
that David kooris just like what are the
kids like like what school they are he
starts with like what will people think
is cool and then that works backwards to
a 16 year olds brain from there well and
I also think that he is analogous to
Pucci as well because in the same
episode there I believe it's when
they're trying to come up with the dog's
name and the executive is just like goes
to his writers and he's like we need a
name for a character like a dog with
attitude you know like like Poochie but
different I think through whatever it
goes like Poochie okay with everyone
else like yeah and I feel like that's
what every superhero genre has done
since blaze like the the executives just
like we need somebody like David s Goyer
that's gonna bring an attitude to this
like someone like David s Goyer any
leaves ever smart more so than JJ Abrams
you know more so than Joss Whedon
there's like the Goyer streak that runs
through movies ladies did today Ghost
Rider and Man Batman Superman it is
insane when you look at the number of
properties that the guy has touch did
another deep dive on Gore so Corey died
now you know let's keep going kids
listening to these days in three two or
we're triplets superhero films that the
press just kind of forgot existed okay
look it's fine you don't remember meteor
man but there were three of these pause
is gonna be some well actually saying
that meteor man was not a Marvel comic
book hero he was they had they released
a six-issue marvel run of meteor man so
he does indeed count as well there's a
sliding scale of getting it wrong cuz
some outlets are just like the first
black person in a movie the sofa did not
research this at all and yes we are look
it's a little bit of a stretch but we
are gonna ride that technicality to the
bank that there was a meteor man Marvel
comic book yeah there you go
well there are they're supposed to be
saying like like you know for the first
time there's a black led superhero movie
like that's objectively not true that's
not even to mention spawn which is also
and steel of course so yeah people
forget the cousins in the 90s I guess
and then but blade this late
three of them these three yeah so good
they made a trilogy and it's also the
Deadpool thing you know like there were
so many think pieces we like - when
Deadpool is coming is like can an
r-rated superhero movie find success
like yeah yeah first what Watchmen was
an r-rated movie a superior movie as was
blade there were three of them and not
only I mean like I'll let you forget
spawn and steel because steel was
terrible and did poorly spawn was
terrible it was spawn was so good people
weren't ready for it yeah they weren't
prepared and they were too afraid to go
to the theater and experience a movie
that solid yeah was so good people were
scared of God it's like reverse
word-of-mouth like people came back so
changed yeah want to also have to go see
did you see spawn no words no words but
the story around can a kind of black
let's superhero movie worker can an
r-rated superhero movie work should have
been it worked so well that blade is why
they got to do x-men which is why they
got to and why they got to do man man
you worked so well and yeah everybody
just kind of forgot yeah blade was the
first successful mm-hmm Marvel movie
like I guess it was the Howard Howard
the Duck if you want to talk fee at
Raqqah be released it was it Howard the
Duck like eight Punishers blade like as
far as like theatricals how would the
duck play to the Captain America was on
video got over Caesars Punisher was on
video there's the Corbin's Fantastic
Four but it's like blade was the thing
that came before x-men came for
spider-man came before it like it's like
it was blade and there will also be
someone in the comments it's like
Punisher war zone or Punisher fight van
or Punisher
post your punch guns are really
underrated did very well and yeah this
guy this guy with the swords and the
one-liners successful all around I think
now a big part of his like what people
say Marvel they only refer to the MCU
and there's like there are there's more
10 years worth of movies 10 years and
also last year
Logan was marvelous people think Marvel
is only confined to like Disney's like
no that's all Marvel yeah
yeah let's keep going fine you don't
remember meteor man but there were three
of these feet Wesley Snipes a badass
never aging samurai who in these films
goes by the name blade I was born ready
mother that's my favorite line read in
any reviews of melanin you can Hearst
and sunlight a signature style and
whatever one-liners Wesley Snipes had in
his head at the time Karolina you tell
him it's open season and also games some
[ __ ] are always trying to ice
skate on bill
they sure are Wesley hey sure wait what
passage China I skin up hill the way I
think yeah you have to really unpack
their truck doesn't mean I mean it's
time to do difficult things yeah
but why won't it's like I had it I had
it and it left what does it mean Joe
it's like for one thing like why would
you do that
right why would you go out of your way
to do something that difficult right you
had to put on the skates you had to find
an uphill I see you went out of your way
to do all this impossible [ __ ] now
you're falling on your ass trying to ice
skate uphill yeah some [ __ ]
always trying to give him the context to
where plays in the film is after he
kills like a super vampire who's like
very much not when I think I skate
uphill I think clumsy I think like
wasted work it's like inefficient you
know he's it's like the wrong tool for
the job I just give us a lesson in
hubris okay I felt like you say listen
you could have just been a vampire yeah
you could have just lived underground
and done your vampire thing run
alongside subway train do whatever you
do you and I would probably never have
crossed paths however you had that try
to ice skate uphill and become the
vampire God and now you have a sore head
that the center for that would have been
like some of the [ __ ] are always
trying to ice skate in public or like
ice skate where they don't belong you
know this was uphill it's just like it's
a thing that ice skates weren't designed
to do and the vampires weren't designed
to open portals and become it okay where
is it
you're not supposed to ice-skate you
know like in a forbidden room uterus I
think it speaks to how highly blade
thinks of himself yeah okay yeah well I
hope we had arrived at a greater
understanding of that let's keep
watching
sure wait what enter a centuries-long
war against the most pathetic vampire
since Twilight who burst into flames at
the slightest touch of silver garlic or
sunlight practice an ancient one at a
time fighting styles but they only have
one master plan blades blood is the key
we're going to harvest your blood what
is this place it's a blood farming
facility speak to their faith we really
missed an opportunity to put in the
Garth merengue dark place clip again
which we did for another Australia I
can't remember what it was but blood not
sticky blood blood blood bits of sin in
like a Stephen King video oh yeah it's
guys snuck it into one all right well
watch Garth Frankie's dark places it's
one of the best shows in facilitating
can't really speak through their face
and name everything by slapping the word
vampire in front of a now catch damn
vampire vampire vampire vampire reg
sometime nation Empire
Sampada bana boy that entire vibrators
vampire race that part trailer compared
to vampire Jim you made a goddamn
vampire Pomeranian that's not just lazy
that's vampire lazy Oh real at an action
franchise with a unique look that it
abandoned to look as much like the
matrix as possible full of early 2000s
club praise leather trench coats and CGI
that was looking so rough they bailed on
it before the final cut are we having
fun yet played it's all good change so
relive what they had was a trilogy with
more first than you can shake a steak at
like marbles first movie franchise the
first black superhero movie franchise
Ryan Reynolds first smartass comic book
roll the first Marvel hallway fight
scene the first Marvel franchise to have
a solid origin story and even better
sequel then go off the rails in the
third one and the first franchise to
include the phrase juggling Thunder
Thunder fun fact John wouldn't say that
because his kids were in the room when
he was recording I think he said
cop we have to see we have to be a see
Casey cook juggling it was cooked yeah
cook juggling Thunder cart can't cart
cart can't let's cook juggling Thunder
can't yeah I think that's the TV that's
the TV edit I hope yeah
first by the way this first franchise
that means franchise more than one movie
franchise people not movie franchise and
differents franchise thank you Dan I
just anticipating perhaps that's the
shows for yep juggling thunder juggling
thunder yeah I'm gonna bet that's one
record they won't be broken looking to
you Deadpool 2 starring white men can't
slay sucked dynasty Vampire Weekend
Terrell what are you doing here
frat pool where's his busy be hell boys
to man
for I've gotten to main character
appropriate words for you Joe had to
feel be driver techno vampire sewing
children had play and then running away
it's just the weirdest riding hood chief
of vampire play every time that a Goyer
thing I don't know I guess throw a baby
at me what's the big what he slew with
the shadows that was the late first nice
trying to turn for anything awful bad
blade rarity it still gave us some of
the best behind-the-scenes stories of
all time we were in Vancouver and Wesley
Snipes was going crazy he would only
answer to the name blade he would
communicate with with post-its that he
would give to the director and each one
he would sign blade he knows this Pete
Holmes yeah
dopey home yeah and that shows crashings
really good to see anyway he did some
good sketches x-men sketches yeah I
think that was the same show then yeah
let's watch some deleted scenes from the
old Blade trilogy starring just nurse
Lee the Vampire Slayer always fight on
black Dame an agent a human vape n oh
yeah Deadpool 1.0 best in booby the
Pearl man norman bleeders
hey Buffy the Vampire Slayer
play tricks and Wesley brah Stoker's
Dracula that's pretty good night of the
raving dead sure played bubby love that
you're getting rid of all the vampires
but we got to work on that wording when
you're talking about a genocide vampire
final solution when I go to a blood rave
I mean it's wrong but it looks like
super fun right I mean sick party but
you don't know where islet but it's been
or if it'll even wash out of my pleather
shirt that's good I'm in how'd it get it
into the sprinkler system you'd have to
tap into the pipes vampire pipes but
I'll bet that they had to water that
blood down because blood would get
swagulated regulate you got a bet they
were thinning that blood pretty heavily
mmm yeah yeah but I posed the question
would you go to a blood rave if you knew
you wouldn't be found out no no maybe
just once for the story yeah exactly
you're gonna just check it out yeah yeah
also really good opening sequence and
that was so good yeah that guy slowly
realized yeah just this random frat guy
realizing that he is not at a great
place for yes oh oh no been sold out
yeah yeah yeah blood brave blade comes
in and just like kills a bunch of
vampires yep that's so much vampires yes
so many times it's just like room full
of vampires blade comes in says
something
repeat that was that's how you directed
Wesley Snipes like all right Wesley
you're gonna walk in you're gonna say
something and you're gonna kill us we
kill a bunch of vampires what am I gonna
say you'll figure it out figure it out
it seems to me that the only thing
keeping blade from ultimately winning
the war is that the vampires are a
secret because let the secret out and
anyone can kill a vampire cuz they're so
easy to kill oh yeah just like throw a
clove of garlic at ya ha ha I just had
to go to Trader Joe's that morning and I
can kill you're right so many vampire
really shoulda just publish
sighs it'd be like PSA guys yeah really
anything will kill them a stern look
yeah yeah lift the finger cross yeah
solid crack about their parents yeah
anything nice skating advice
yeah ice skating advise jeez yeah well I
want to see the blade Twilight cross
over I want to bring it back it's one of
its one of the all-time great memes an
all-time great meme I just I like two of
these three movies a lot so this wasn't
this wasn't easy to do because I like
three of these three movies a lot it's
not a good movie no but I will always
watch it because it's because you like
Triple H yeah you like watching him rest
vampire resting Triple H BAM fire
wrestle in his super cool polo that was
just the epitome of vampire cool all the
other vampires are walking around in
like dusters and like pleather outfits
and he's like hey here's my polo and my
fanny pack
vampire yeah it's awesome but Jessica
Biel has a laser bow-and-arrow she does
she doesn't she like tricks vampires
into into like okay there's another baby
dead baby fake out in this movie when
she goes into the subway yeah oh yeah
there's a baby that's spray it says [ __ ]
you or something really the tables
something really like intense that David
Goyer wrote yeah you just said something
badass is written on the baby David
[Laughter]
anyways that's blade well because to be
amical brothers what are we gonna do
next week I think it's gonna be
something hero themed will unite some
some heroes all under one roof finally
yeah I think we'll be united in our
opinion hopefully well it yeah
tune in next week to see how many
punches we pulled or didn't in our
honest trailer for the film we've been
referencing
couple together next week comes again
take on booyah [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you